Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Nous allons parler des relations
toxiques au travail.
Quand vous entendez ces mots,
« relations toxiques au travail »,
qu’est-ce que ça vous évoque ?
Est-ce que, comme moi,
des visages vous viennent à l’esprit ?
Est-ce que, comme moi, vous avez
des sensations qui apparaissent,
des sensations désagréables ?
Peut-être une tension,
peut-être une boule ici, peut-être là.
Est-ce que c’est de la peur ?
Est-ce que c’est du dégoût ?
Est-ce que c’est de la colère ?
Est-ce que c’est peut-être
un mélange de tout ça ?
Si nous avons des sensations aussi vives
quand nous pensons
à ces relations toxiques,
c’est qu’elles nous marquent profondément
et qu’elles nous laissent des cicatrices.
L’objectif de ce partage,
c’est de vous amener peut-être
à poser un regard différent
sur ces relations toxiques
grâce à l’éclairage des neurosciences
et des sciences du comportement
pour découvrir en quoi il est urgent
et important de s’en occuper.
Nous allons voir comment elles dégradent
la performance et le bien-être au travail
et nous verrons ensuite
quelles sont les solutions disponibles
pour lutter contre ce véritable fléau.
D’après vous,
à quoi est-ce qu’on reconnaît
le caractère toxique d’une relation,
sachant qu’il est tout à fait normal
de rencontrer des accrocs,
des tensions, des conflits
dans les relations les plus saines ?
J’ai choisi le monde des insectes
pour vous donner quelques exemples
de comportements toxiques.
Vous avez par exemple le bourdon.
Vous savez, celui qui ne vous lâche pas.
Il est sur votre dos et au lieu
de vous laisser travailler en paix,
il contrôle tout ce que vous faites.
Il y a aussi la punaise.
Vous savez, c’est la personne
qui va lancer une petite phrase perfide,
un sous-entendu.
C’est la personne qui va bouder
pendant quinze jours
parce que vous n’avez pas
été d’accord avec elle.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
les comportements passifs-agressifs.
En fait, c'est de l'agression
qui ne s'assume pas.
D’ailleurs, si vous lui demandez :
« Mais pourquoi tu fais la tête
depuis quelques jours ? »,
elle va vous dire :
« Pas du tout, tout va bien. »
On a aussi la sangsue.
Avec la sangsue,
rien ne va jamais.
C’est une victime
qui se plaint en permanence.
Elle s’accroche à vous
et elle déverse en vous ses malheurs.
Et pendant ce temps-là,
elle pompe toute votre énergie.
Il y a aussi le moustique.
Le moustique, c’est celui qui vous irrite.
Il est insistant :
vous le chassez, il revient.
Le moustique n’accepte pas
qu’on lui dise non.
Et enfin -
mais la liste n’est pas exhaustive -
je vais terminer par le scorpion.
Le scorpion, c’est le plus terrible,
parce qu’il détruit,
il détruit les autres,
il exploite, il abuse, il dénigre,
il rabaisse, il humilie.
C'est le niveau zéro de l'empathie.
C'est un prédateur.
Et il est d’autant plus dangereux
qu’il avance masqué.
Parce qu’il sait très bien faire
du charme aux gens bien placés
dont il a besoin pour avancer.
Il sait parfaitement les embobiner
pendant qu’il détruit la vie des autres.
Peut-être avez-vous reconnu
quelques personnages
dans votre entourage professionnel.
Quelles sont les caractéristiques
des comportements toxiques?
Il y en a trois.
Ils se répètent,
ils dégradent la performance et le
bien-être des personnes qui les subissent.
Et enfin, ils sont intentionnels ou pas.
Et ça, c’est important de le savoir
parce que ces comportements
toxiques peuvent venir
de personnes tout à fait
bien intentionnées.
Par exemple, le bourdon,
ça peut être un manager très anxieux
qui est dans l’hyper-contrôle.
Il soigne son anxiété de façon inadaptée
en vérifiant tout
et en démotivant les troupes.
Il dégrade la performance
en croyant  la servir.
Les chercheurs ont montré que
ces comportements toxiques perturbent
le fonctionnement du cerveau
de ceux qui les subissent.
Il y a plusieurs types de perturbations.
Par exemple,
est-ce que ça vous est
déjà arrivé en réunion
de recevoir en pleine figure
ce que j’appelle un Scud ?
Vous savez, la vacherie qu’on se prend
de préférence en présence du big boss ?
Qu’est-ce que ça provoque
dans le cerveau de la victime ?
C’est un phénomène qu’on appelle
la bascule des émotions,
c’est-à-dire une brusque
montée des émotions
qui fait littéralement plonger
les capacités du cerveau exécutif,
celui qui nous permet de réfléchir.
C’est pour ça que d’un seul coup,
on a un grand blanc,
on ne sait pas quoi répondre,
on est complètement désemparé.
Et c’est seulement
quand l’émotion se calme
et qu’on est sorti de la réunion,
que d’un seul coup, on se dit :
« Mais pourquoi je ne lui ai pas répondu
ça ? La réponse était évidente. »
En fait, la réponse a toujours été là.
Simplement, on n’avait plus accès
à son intelligence.
Et quand l’émotion se calme,
on retrouve littéralement ses esprits.
C’est pour ça que l’OCDE a produit
un rapport il y a quelques années de ça,
un rapport international
pour mettre en garde les enseignants
sur le fait que les émotions négatives
agissent de façon pénalisante
sur le cerveau
et empêchent les élèves d’apprendre.
C’est vrai pour les élèves, pour
les professionnels dans les organisations.
Les comportements toxiques,
quand ils se multiplient,
entraînent un véritable stress chronique.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un stress social.
Cela se traduit par un sentiment
d’insécurité plus ou moins latent.
Parfois, on en est à peine conscient,
mais on se rend compte
qu’on est un peu tendu.
C’est lié à une montée
du taux de cortisol.
Le cortisol, c’est une hormone du stress.
On en a besoin.
En quantité normale, tout va bien,
mais quand elle commence
à monter trop en niveau,
ça produit des perturbations,
ça détruit des neurones
et ça vient perturber tout le métabolisme,
ce qui épuise notre organisme.
Du coup, la résolution de problèmes
est dégradée,
la créativité disparaît complétement
et l’apprentissage est réduit,
voire bloqué.
Comment ça se fait ?
Pour comprendre ça, il faut comprendre
que la priorité numéro un du cerveau,
c’est de s’occuper de notre sécurité.
Ce qui fait que quand
on ressent de l’insécurité,
notre cerveau va se concentrer
sur la source de cette insécurité.
On se met à épier tout ce qui
se passe autour de nous,
On imagine des scénarios catastrophes,
on déploie une énergie considérable
pour se protéger.
Et du coup, on a du mal à se concentrer
et on travaille en mode dégradé.
En plus, quand on vit
dans cette tension permanente,
on devient paranoïaque
et on devient individualiste.
On ne fait plus confiance à personne
et ça nous conduit à nous comporter
nous-même de façon toxique.
Vous voyez, c’est vraiment
un cercle vicieux.
Pourquoi est-ce que les relations
qui dysfonctionnent comme ça
nous font autant souffrir ?
C’est lié à une fonction essentielle
de notre cerveau
qu’on appelle le cerveau social.
C'est aussi une découverte récente
des neurosciences.
Nous sommes équipés
d’un énorme réseau de neurones
programmé pour nous pousser
à collaborer les uns avec les autres.
Les humains, comme les autres espèces
sociales, sont interdépendants.
Cela veut dire que  de notre entente
dépend notre survie.
C’est pour ça que quand
ça se passe mal dans nos relations,
nous sommes aussi contrariés.
C’est pour ça que ça nous obsède,
qu’on s’épuise à repasser en boucle
le scénario de ce qui s’est passé.
C’est comme ça qu’on dilapide
son énergie mentale en rumination,
on se sent mal
et on n’arrive pas à travailler.
Alors, que faire ?
Tout l’enjeu va consister à restaurer
la sécurité psychologique des individus,
tout simplement pour qu’ils retrouvent
un fonctionnement optimal de leur cerveau
au travail.
Pour ça, il va falloir agir
sur les comportements.
La recherche a bien établi
que le comportement résulte
de l’interaction entre l’individu
et son environnement
et il va falloir agir aux deux niveaux.
Commençons par l'environnement.
L’urgence et la priorité, ça va être
de neutraliser les Scorpions.
Il existe des noms techniques
pour désigner ces scorpions.
Peu importe ces noms,
ce qu’il faut savoir,
c’est que ce sont en quelque sorte
des psychopathes en col blanc
et qu’ils causent le niveau maximum
d’insécurité dans une organisation.
Leur influence est d’autant plus délétère
que, comme ils sont manipulateurs
et sans scrupules,
ils montent très vite
les échelons de la hiérarchie.
L'idéal, c'est d'éviter de les recruter.
Le problème, c’est que le scorpion excelle
aux entretiens de recrutement.
C’est à tel point que,
si vous êtes un recruteur
ou si vous êtes amené à recruter quelqu’un
et que vous êtes littéralement
subjugué par le candidat,
ça doit constituer en soi
un signal d’alarme.
Il est important de se former
à repérer ces profils
et de se former à les neutraliser
si on les a dans son organisation.
Il faut savoir
qu’il y en aurait plus de 4 à 5 %
dans les organisations,
ce qui est énorme.
Des chercheurs de Harvard ont montré
qu’il est beaucoup plus rentable
de se débarrasser d’un scorpion
que de recruter un talent,
même exceptionnel.
Au niveau de l’environnement,
il faut communiquer sur ce sujet
des relations toxiques,
au même titre que sur tous les sujets
importants pour l’organisation.
Il faut mettre en place
des règles avec des incentives
pour encourager les comportements
de collaboration
et des sanctions pour décourager
les comportements toxiques.
Cela passe par une culture du feedback et
un feedback quotidien et pluri-quotidien.
Au niveau de l’environnement,
ça passe aussi par l’exemplarité,
c’est-à-dire que le comportement
des leaders les plus haut placés
donne le la dans les organisations.
Ils sont imités par tout le monde.
Au niveau des individus,
qu’est-ce qu’on va pouvoir faire ?
Là aussi, on va les sensibiliser
et surtout, on va les former
à des compétences qui apparaissent
comme des compétences nouvelles
qui sont les compétences
socio-émotionnelles.
Le but de ces compétences, c’est
de développer l’individu à deux niveaux,
dans la relation à soi.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire par exemple :
« Est-ce que je suis conscient de l’impact
que mes attitudes et comportements
ont sur les autres ? »
Ça, c'est le niveau de conscience.
Mais est-ce que je suis capable
aussi de réguler mes émotions ?
Est-ce que je sais prendre
en charge ma frustration ?
Est-ce que je sais quoi faire
de mon découragement, de ma colère ?
Est-ce que je sais comment réguler
mon stress en quelques minutes
pour retrouver mon calme ?
Est-ce que je sais comment me détendre ?
Même en situation de crise ?
Ça, c’est la relation à soi
et de la relation à soi dépend
la relation à l’autre.
Dans la relation à l’autre,
on peut se poser la question :
« Est-ce que je suis ouvert à l’autre ? Et
est-ce que je sais l’écouter vraiment ? »
Les chercheurs ont démontré que quand
on pose cette question à un groupe,
la grande majorité va se trouver
supérieure à la moyenne,
ce qui évidemment est
mathématiquement impossible.
On se surestime systématiquement,
surtout dans ce domaine.
Il n’existe qu’un seul moyen fiable
de répondre à cette question,
c’est de poser la question aux autres.
Et la relation à l’autre, c’est aussi :
« Est-ce que je suis capable
de calmer quelqu’un qui est énervé ? »
« Est-ce que je suis capable de résoudre
un conflit dans un groupe ? »
À l’ère digitale, nous vivons dans un
environnement volatil, instable, incertain
et nous devons résoudre
des problèmes complexes.
Avoir des exécutants ne suffit plus.
Il faut des personnes,
des professionnels engagés
et en pleine possession de
toutes leurs capacités mentales.
Et c’est pour ça que ces fameuses
compétences dites socio-émotionnelles
sont devenues indispensables.
Le problème, c’est qu’elles font
cruellement défaut. Pourquoi ?
Tout simplement parce qu'elles ne sont pas
enseignées de façon traditionnelle.
Dans un rapport récent du Forum économique
mondial sur l’avenir de l’apprentissage,
les experts mettent en lumière
un véritable skill gap.
Ce qui se traduit par un trou
de compétences au 21ème siècle,
et ce trou de compétences concerne
en particulier les compétences
socio-émotionnelles.
On peut facilement s'en rendre compte.
Regardez le chaos que
la crise sanitaire nous a apporté.
Le problème ?
Ce n’est pas un manque de compétences,
ce n’est pas un manque d’expertise,
ce n’est pas un manque de savoir-faire,
ce n’est pas un manque de technologie,
ce n’est pas un manque d’effort.
Le problème,
ce sont les relations toxiques à l’œuvre
qui sabotent toutes les possibilités
de collaboration.
Or, face aux défis énormes
de notre siècle,
nous ne pourrons réussir
que si nous réunissons nos forces.
Et pour cela,
nous devons acquérir les compétences
qui vont nous apprendre à le faire.
Les machines intelligentes sont
en train de nous remplacer
dans un grand nombre de nos fonctions.
Et il y a un terrain sur lequel
elles ne peuvent pas aller.
C’est celui des relations. Pourquoi ?
Tout simplement parce que
la machine n’a pas d’émotions.
Or, la clé de voûte de la motivation
à collaborer, c’est ce qu’on ressent.
Si on ne se sent pas en sécurité, si on ne
se sent pas en confiance avec les autres,
on ne collabore pas.
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que ces
compétences peuvent s’acquérir à tout âge.
Ce sont des compétences particulières
en ceci qu’elles ne relèvent pas
de l’intellect.
C’est pour ça que les individus
les plus brillants
peuvent être incapables de motiver une
équipe ou de s’entendre avec les autres.
Ce sont des compétences
qui demandent du courage
parce qu’il faut accepter
de se regarder en face pour voir
ce que les autres voient en nous.
Parce que nous avons un angle mort qui
nous empêche de nous voir objectivement.
Et le seul moyen de prendre connaissance
de ce qui occupe cet angle mort,
c’est le feedback, c’est-à-dire demander
aux autres ce qu’ils en pensent.
Mais pour cela, il faut
un feedback bienveillant
parce que ça peut être un choc de
découvrir l’effet qu’on fait aux autres.
On a de bonnes surprises et
on en a de beaucoup moins bonnes.
Aujourd’hui, sur le terrain,
quand je travaille avec les entreprises,
que ce soit de très grandes
entreprises ou des plus petites,
j’entends constamment
le terme « disruption ».
Il faut innover, il faut être créatif,
il faut de la disruption.
Et je me dis que peut-être aujourd’hui,
la plus grande disruption
qu’on pourrait apporter,
ce serait,
tous,
d’apprendre ces compétences
socio-émotionnelles
pour réussir à travailler ensemble,
pour réussir à collaborer.
Et ça ne veut pas dire vivre
dans le monde de Oui-Oui.
Pas du tout.
Parce que l’idée,
c’est justement de réussir à ne pas
être d’accord sans se taper dessus.
Et ça, ça relève d'une compétence.
Je vous invite à faire dès aujourd’hui,
si vous voulez faire un premier pas
dans ces compétences,
c’est d’aller voir des collègues que
vous trouvez sympas et de leur dire :
« Comment tu te sens en face de moi ? »
« Qu’est-ce que je fais
qui te met en insécurité ? »
« Qu’est-ce que je fais qui,
au contraire, te sécurise ? »
La bonne nouvelle avec les
compétences socio-émotionnelles,
c’est que ce n’est pas seulement
éliminer les comportements toxiques,
c’est aussi développer
les comportements constructifs.
C’est permettre à toutes les personnalités
formidables qui occupent les entreprises
de s’épanouir.
Et peut-être que c’est ça,
la prochaine disruption qui nous attend.